[Music]
welcome to net 204 connecting your data
center to cloud approach for a
mission-critical network reliability my
name is Nick de Cristo Faro I'm a
customer engineer here at Google
specializing in Google's Google cloud
network so first let's talk about
Google's network so when we talk about
Google's network we're talking about a
massive global platform as you can see a
hundred and thirty four points of
presence massive investments in subsea
cabals connecting the world as you can
see behind me all within a private
backbone network that we own or that we
have private connectivity for the map
here clearly distinct some regions that
we have of course also future regions
that we're planning to launch as well as
the mast point of presence that we have
to connecting your data center to the
cloud so let's talk about about how you
connect Google to the cloud so
connecting your place to our place we
actually have five ways of connecting
Google to the cloud we divide these into
two different sections public addressing
and private addressing the ladder at the
top is the public addressing method
which is actually connecting Google via
the various means of peering so direct
peering is one of them which offers the
ability to connect to Google via
standard peering that you would do with
an internet exchange essentially
connecting your public prefixes so
public address blocks that you would own
to Google cloud via standard BGP peering
on the top right hand side we talked
about carrier peering carrier peering is
essentially the same means of connecting
to Google via public addressing however
through a carrier that provides that
connectivity so this is in case for
example you do not have the connectivity
to Google directly to be able to meet us
at our peering facilities you can do
that through a carrier on the bottom
part we speak about private addressing
now this is really interesting for
enterprise environments where you want
to extend connectivity from your
on-premise environment using private RFC
1918 addressing and connecting directly
to Google Cloud so that means being able
to reach directly your on-prem workloads
to Google
cloud via two means of connectivity and
then of course we have the VPN option
which kind of sits hybrid in the middle
which provides a mix of connectivity
across public internet links to do the
private addressing extending your own
primitive armament to the cloud so when
you speak of private addressing we
actually have two Metz's methods of
doing this once it's dedicated
interconnect which is to directly
connect to Google cloud via one of our
various points of presence that means
your equipment is co-located in a point
of presence or you have connectivity to
our point of presence and establishing a
dedicated link to us the partner
interconnect offering is actually to
provide connectivity again privately
however through a partner a service
provider that is able to extend the last
mile connectivity from your on-premise
environment to Google Cloud in case you
do not have connectivity in one of our
points of presence you can use a partner
interconnect to do that for you and as a
hybrid model as I mentioned VPN is a way
to connect via public internet links and
often enterprises start that way before
actually moving on to purchase a
dedicated or a partner interconnect
offering and I will show you later on
actually how seamlessly the transition
is done between a VPN connectivity to
Google cloud through a partner dedicated
interconnect link so speak a bit about
the cloud interconnect but first I'm
pleased to announce that we are
announcing 100 Gig connections on our
pops so now you're able to connect not
only with 10 gigs but now with 100 gig
100 gig connections at our points of
presence so cloud interconnect as I
mentioned is a method to provide access
to private RFC 1918 addressing from your
on-prem workloads directly to the cloud
and it enables essentially a hybrid
cloud connectivity model and does not
require the use of management of
hardware VPN devices because this is
something that you directly connect your
on-premise router to us via various
publications that were located in so
from the left-hand side here we see
dedicated interconnect as I mentioned we
can do 10 gigs now we can do 100 gigs we
can provide an LACP bundle so a link
route bundle from 8 x 10 gigs or 2 x 100
gigs per provided transport circuits
directly to our cloud environment from
your on-premise data center and a
partner interconnect provides dedicated
bandwidth
for subcircuit rates starting at 50
megabits all the way to 10 gigs provided
through a service provider network so
here's a bit about how the inter connect
deployment looks like so we can look at
a dedicated interconnect in this myth in
this way we have a colocation facility
in the middle the colocation facility is
essentially where you would meet us at
one of our points of presents so you may
either have a cage already established
in one of the facilities for example
some of the Equinix facilities is a very
common colocation facility or any other
colocation facilities or you can extend
connectivity there through through one
of any kind of telco providers that can
extend that connectivity to you and from
that you extend your on-premise
connection to your data center and we
provide connectivity to our cloud
network now here's a list of our
interconnect locations so as you can see
we're present all around the world in
all the continents except of course
Antarctica and then we have connectivity
with low latency links which is the dark
green circles which are providing very
little agency access to Google cloud
resources if you need a high highly low
latency access between your workloads
and Google cloud so that means you can
provide sub 5 milliseconds on average
from these sites to any regions that are
located in these points and presents
looking at the partner interconnect
offering this is essentially a model
where the partner is essentially
providing the connection to Google so
partners have established a partner
relationship with us already there
they've established connectivity with us
and they provide that last mile
connectivity to their clients so various
partners offer that and if you're not
looking for something at ten gigs and
potentially higher throughput you would
look at a partner to offer for that
because they can provide subcircuit
rates from 50 megabits all the way up to
10 gigs so they can provide that
solution and also one thing that some
partners are able to offer as well is
that they can minimize the router
requirements you may not need a router
at the colocation facility themselves in
case you want to do something like a
multi cloud scenario and connect
cloud-to-cloud some partners offer the
ability to connect to clouds together
via a virtual cloud virtual router
offering
so let's look at some of the distinction
between partner and dedicated
interconnect so why would you choose
partner why would you choose dedicated I
talk to a lot of customers depending on
their use case it's very clear partner
is where you're not able to have access
to our points of presence you're not
physically co-located in a point of
presence you may not need to have you
may not need to have a requirement of 10
gigs right you don't need 10 gigs which
is the minimum that we can offer with
dedicated interconnect therefore a
partner will provide you a subcircuit
rate starting from 50 megabits all the
way to 10 gigs and we can provide that
by a v-line attachments on our end you
pay only for what you need SLA is
require at least I have to beeline
attachments which would terminate at two
different availability zones within a
metro area if you want to have an SLA of
three nines and then four nines you
would just establish that across two
different metropolitan areas you can
actually also establish with partner
interconnect you don't need to be within
one org we can actually extend the
connectivity from multiple orgs because
the partner interconnect VLANs can land
in different organizational units within
the UCP for dedicated it's often used by
customers that require high throughput
they require minimum of 10 gigs the
customer would essentially meet us at
one of our pops or again extend
connectivity to one of our pops either
by a service provider or meet us
physically in one of our point of
presence all the VLANs are actually
riding on the same physical link so that
means that when you establish VLAN
attachments through the through our
cloud console you would actually
establish the VLAN attachments within
the same physical circuit that's
established with us SLA is again require
at least two connections to one of our
201 metro area across to availability
zones and then all VLANs need to land in
the same organizational unit and GCP for
dedicated interconnect that means that
you can establish a project in GCP
within within one org and that project
can share its resources but it's still
bound by the organization that's one of
the advantages that the partner
interconnect can do is you can actually
spend that across multiple organization
if you need to
so let's talk about a few different ways
that you can actually use inter connect
on some of the use cases that our
customers are using today so here's just
an example again of the private routing
that you can establish between
on-premise and your between your
on-premise infrastructure and our cloud
environment so essentially would
establish a BGP peer via our our
offering which is called a cloud router
which would be deployed in the cloud
region and an established BGP peering
with your on-premise router and
exchanging prefixes in this case here we
have a headquarter with an external data
center that has a some you know a
network of 192 168 50 5.0 / 24 and we're
advertising that to the cloud region and
the cloud regions receiving that prefix
/ BGP and the cloud region has 192 168
49.0 / 24 and we're advertising that
across so we can establish that
connectivity through through the cloud
router which is our virtual BGP speaker
in the cloud and your on-premise BGP
speaker another use case that we've seen
is because of the concept of global
routing and the concept of our global
network we're essentially able to deploy
within one VPC multiple regions so that
actually allows you to connect with one
router that you deploy in one region
other you can actually reach natively
other regions within GCP so that means
that we're able to advertise prefixes
that would exist let's say in a
different region then the region where
the cloud router is deployed and you can
actually ride the backbone of Google's
network to provide connectivity between
these regions you do not need to
duplicate your effort and building
separate cloud router instances in
different regions this is done natively
through our global backbone network it's
a flag that's enabled in cloud router
when you actually deploy this called
global routing it labels you to
seamlessly transition our network and
allow access to remote regions from the
cloud routers region DNS is another one
of our very popular solutions as well
customers would like to deploy on
premise
they have on-premise already a DNS
server where they have host names that
they're resolving for their private you
know private resources on on-prem and
then they also want to deploy resources
in the cloud so they would use cloud DNS
in the cloud specify specific a records
for different
no vm's that they spin up within the
cloud and they would want their
on-premise environment to also resolve
hostnames in the cloud so they would do
that via DNS 14 we have both inbound and
outbound dns forwarding which actually
allows you to resolve hostnames from
on-premise workloads to the cloud and
also from the cloud to on-premise
workloads and we can allow that through
the means of interconnect so by either a
dedicated or partner interconnect or
through VPN we're able to extend that
connectivity via the means of DNS
forwarding another great offering is
through the shared VPC model so within
Google Cloud we're able to deploy a
model by a shared BBC which essentially
structures a host project which is
essentially the anchor for all your
networking resources within the cloud so
service projects do not need to worry
about networking they just need to
consume resources they can be
development teams that just want to
deploy applications they don't need to
know about the underlying networking
infrastructure the routing the subnets
the firewall policies this is all done
by a centralized networking project that
would be managed by generally a
networking team within your organization
and that project would deploy cloud
router within a region and in that cloud
router can essentially share the
resources of the interconnect with the
individual service project so the
service project would consume networking
resources similar to subnets that you
would grant them access to and it can
natively route with any routing that's
available within the host project to
your on-premise environment so again
it's really simplifies the model you
don't need to duplicate multiple
interconnections in each project you can
actually centralize this have a central
Network administration team that manages
the networking for your environment and
the rest of the the teams that need to
manage development projects or other
types of service projects do not need to
worry about networking and they're
essentially connected back to your
on-premise environment via policies that
you set another use case is connecting
privately to Google services Google has
many api's that can be exposed for
example cloud storage or bigquery that
you may want to utilize from on-premise
and also because you have a dedicated
link to Google is a good benefit to be
able to use that link with low latency
access high throughput to be able to
store data to let's say a cloud storage
bucket or to load data into bigquery
services so it can actually advertise by
a single via VIP rain
back to your on-premise environment at
that API that you can call and then you
can actually make calls to Google Cloud
API services that are available through
this API so this supports Google API
endpoints there's a subset of endpoints
that's currently supported with us and
essentially on-premise what you would do
is you do a DNS change to rewrite the
Google API domain to use a specific VIP
of it range that allows you to connect
to these to these prefixes through an
interconnect link and you would
advertise that prefix which is you can
see in this example here it's 199 36 150
3.4 / 30 on the cloud router back to
your on-premise environment so the cloud
router actually allows you to program
which routes you will want to advertise
and by advertising this range making the
necessary DNS changes you can actually
connect back to on Prem to Google API
services natively let's talk a bit about
high high availability topologies so one
circuit as I mentioned earlier does not
give you any kind of SLA s to have an
SLA you need to have two circuits for
redundancy so in this case we have a
colocation facility which is located in
one metropolitan area that metropolitan
area would have to availability zones so
to have any kind of SLA a39 SLA with us
you would need to connect across two of
these metropolitan availability zones in
a single Metro so with BGP graceful
restart and cloud router we're able to
provide means of having a high
availability across these two zones now
for customers that require very high
availability we would want to duplicate
that effort across two metropolitan
areas so in this case you may have
Metropolitan Area on the East Coast
maybe one on the west coast and you
would be again connected across two
availability zones within these
metropolitan areas and that would
provide you a 4/9 SLA with us to connect
back to GCP and within GCP you would
deploy a cloud router in one region and
a cloud router in the other region
generally as close as possible to where
you are co-located geographically so if
it's on the west coast you would pick a
region on the west coast and on the East
Coast you would pick a region on the
east coast with the means of global
routing as I mentioned earlier we're
actually able to natively transit our
network in case of failure so if we
would if we were to lose an entire
region we're able a route via the
the region to connect back to your
on-premise environment via this this
model of deployment and now I'd like to
introduce my colleague Sasha onstage to
talk about a high availability cloud VPN
hi I'm Sasha and one of the engineers at
a VPN team and if there is one thing I
learned in my years working for again it
is that reliability is a critical
feature of VPN because if your
connectivity from your on-prem location
to GCP is down you'll feel it across all
organization now the protocol that we
use to run VPN is the Enderson standard
called IPSec it's pretty good
when you consider its encryption
capabilities but its ability to detect
and route around failures is not so good
so if anything fails on the way from TCP
to your location then your tunnel will
be toast and and we want to build a more
reliable connection and to do that
the way is to use redundancy so you can
set up several tunnels running in
parallel between the two location and
hoping that if one is down the other
rule Silvia so that gives you some value
but that's not enough because if those
tunnels share any component on the way
from GCD to your location if there is a
fault in that component again your whole
connection will be down so not only you
need to provide redundant connection you
need to be able to isolate failure by
making sure that no at no stage there is
a single point of failure in which your
tunnels is working now as being Cloud
this is virtualized hardware so where do
you even start so to do that we
developed a new VPN product called high
variability
and for that we have a new kind of cloud
VPN gateway a slightly different from
the old one and what it does it provides
you with two interfaces and you can
think of them as two different network
cards similarly to to the physical
network cards you would put in your
computer so if one of them is burned out
the others are still continuing to run
your traffic but this is virtual so if
you have two tunnels attached to two of
the interfaces we will make sure that
they are nothing they share no line
cards no network connections no machines
no switches actually being cloud we are
pretty sure that they will not even
share data center so they are pretty
much separated and if one of them goes
down the other is still assured and very
likely to be working and then if this
further scenario happens then a short
time after that the system will discover
and that one tunnel went unhealthy and
switch all the traffic over to the
healthy tunnel now how much exactly that
gives you in terms of reliability it's a
good question it's a function of how
good is the isolation and how fast is
the process of switching over from
unhealthy channel to the healthy one and
we did this analysis for our system and
I'm happy to announce that we are going
to provide for nine which is 99.99
regional availability so it means four
and a half minutes of maximum monthly
downtime or 53 minutes yearly and just a
few notes so this is a regional product
you do not need to go multi-regional to
have this level of availability just one
region is enough you will be able to
connect just as with classic European
that we had you'll be able to connect
both GCP to TCP or to your own pram
locations or even to another cloud the
only requirement that is mandatory now
and was optional with classic VPN is
that we need the VPN on the other side
to support dynamic routing if you think
of it it makes total sense because you
want your system to be able to failover
to switch the traffic from one path to
another so it's natural and one last
thing to notice is that when you're
providing this redundant connection you
are actually having twice as many
tunnels as you're sure to have in case
there is any system failure so if you
watch the observable capacity that you
have in your bandwidth then it will be
twice as much as you will have assured
and so if there is any failure then your
available bandwidth will will go down by
a factor of two and that's not the time
when you want to discover that you
actually needed more tunnels then you
have configured so to have a consistent
experience of your bandwidth staying
constant all the time what we recommend
is to set up a VPN connection in an
active/passive configuration meaning
that one of the tunnels has priority and
all the traffic flows to it until that
unless that fails and all the traffic
switches over to the other tunnel with
dynamic routing again that's easy to set
up you just use different medval use and
that's it so to recap we have we are
going to provide four lines availability
this system is currently in alpha it's
going to launch together next month and
yeah here is the more traffic running
more smoothly NIC back to you thank you
thank you
okay so putting all that into
perspective now I will actually go
through a demo that looks at a common
enterprise use case where we have an
enterprise that starts with a VPN tunnel
here for example I have a customer
project I have an IPSec tunnel connected
back to a customer router on Prem I set
as sasha was talking about the med
values which are important in terms of
traffic engineering that we're doing
within the interconnect model so in this
case I have a standard med med value of
a hundred and then I would like to set
up another connection this other
connection would be a dedicated or
partner interconnect offering and and I
don't want traffic to switch over to
this connection so I create a connection
create it with a lower med value of 1000
and I establish a link now once that
link is established traffic will not
seamlessly switch over yet because the
value of the med priorities are
preferred over the VPN tunnel then from
the interconnect connection now to do
this a traffic switch over it's very
simple we just switch the med values
between the VPN connection and the
interconnect connection by swapping them
and then the traffic seamlessly moves
over so now I have a VPN connection that
can be used as a backup I can keep it
online case I needed but right now my
traffic would actually be routed across
a dedicated or connector partner
interconnect link so here's the topology
of what we're doing for this demo so I
actually have a hav p.m. so deployed
with two interfaces
they're both deployed an active passive
right now with med value of 100 med
value of 200 so active passive on the
VPN link and then I have my interconnect
links which with higher med values 1000
and 1200 and they're connected back to
an on-premise environment which I'm
running a pink test between that and a
VM within GCP so you can see here I have
this in my cloud console with this
project I just showed the topology so we
have here the interconnect session and
the VPN sessions you can see here the
1000 and a 1200 as advertised route
priority and we can see here the 100 and
200 for my VPN connections my VPN
tunnels
so here I'm running a ping test between
the VM on-prem and n a VM sorry on Prem
workload and in a VM and GCP as you can
see here we have kind of sporadic pings
between 20 to 30 millisecond this is
running across the internet this is a
VPN tunnel it's not predictable do the
path nature of the Internet so I can't
really rely on some guarantee in just
milliseconds it's pretty sporadic it's
flipping up and down I want to now
switch traffic over to a dedicated
interconnect link to have higher
throughput and also lower latency so
here I'm just running a script which is
actually going to set the priorities
swap them between the interconnect and
the VPN tunnels and once the it's really
what I'm doing is I'm switching the
priorities both on the VPN side in GCP
both VPN and err connect side on GC P
and also on Prem from my own Prem router
to make sure that we're updating on both
sides so that it's symmetrical traffic
of course it's important to do that so
that traffic runs both symmetrically
between the peers and once that's
actually completed then we should see
that traffic the latency is going to be
reduced quite significantly because
we're gonna go across the dedicated
interconnect link with much lower with
much lower latency and higher it through
but and as you can see now we've
actually lowered it down once it
stabilizes should be around eight nine
minutes of milliseconds when traffic is
running across the interconnect as you
can see now it's around nine
milliseconds traffic seamlessly moved
over to the interconnect link instead of
the VPN tunnel
and as you can see I've seamlessly
transitioned traffic there's no packet
loss easy to do now you can move traffic
over and you have traffic riding across
the the interconnect link if we look at
the cloud console and refresh it
now we see that the priorities have been
swapped so the inter connect session now
has 100 and 200 that's the preferred
path active passive path across the
interconnect and 1000 1200 for the VPN
tunnels so they're still there in case
we need it as a backup in case there
would be a failure we can still
transitioning our connect so it's that
simple to be able to do a migration
between VPN and air connect seamlessly
between your enterprise and GCP and with
that that is the end of my demo I'd like
to introduce Steve Olsen from the Home
Depot and talk about his a interconnect
experience thank you
[Applause]
hey my name is Steve but everyone calls
me Steve oh you'll have to excuse me
my voice is a little bit under the
weather today caught something here but
we will push forward I've been with the
Home Depot for 12 13 years which means
I'm incredibly tired and I've seen lots
of different things we like to say we've
seen a lot of changes and how many
people in the last five years probably
more than we've seen the past 10 or 15
and that really goes to speak to our
digital transformation things that we've
done we've really put IT first it wasn't
always the case when I first started IT
was kind of a vaccine now I t's kind of
a front seat driver and we've really
done this strategy called interconnected
retail it's really an omni-channel
strategy that lets our customers buy
online pick up in store buy online ship
to their home buy in the store all that
kind of merges together to give the
customer the choice and one of that big
strategies that we played first with
first was the cloud GCP we chose to do
econ 4 and we have a journey that kind
of used the tools and the guys have been
talking about and how we connected to
GCP but first I'm gonna start with some
base facts about Home Depot I won't read
everything on the slide but Home Depot
ones found in 1978 last year we did a
hundred billion one hundred eight
million dollars in sales
dot-com was up 22% I think in sales and
there's some calm guys here but in front
I think in the last five years six years
we've actually increased calm sales by a
billion dollars almost every single year
a lot of that growth has been in our
cloud space we completely replac form
calm and we'll talk about that in just a
second if over 150 supply chain
facilities we have over 2000 stores
spread out across Canada u.s. and Mexico
and of course 400,000 associates what
all that people don't realize is we do
the big IT presence we have over 3,000
IT associates we hired just under a
thousand last year and we're still going
we have offices all across the country
from our various brands that define Home
Depot and companies that we use and with
that I'll start with our actual strategy
and how we start with the cloud
so what kind of led up to a distributed
model for us is really just starting
with e-commerce first in around 2014
we'd completely read platforms the
website it was decided that we would go
from an on-prem model to in the cloud
and some of the reasons are the classic
reasons that you would hear but we were
building our own premise infrastructure
for sales that would be around
Thanksgiving or Black Friday or Father's
Day and you build this infrastructure to
the point where you're using it for
those days only and then the rest of the
year it sits stagnant so we really
wanted a more on-demand infrastructure
that could scale and of course the cloud
came into that with multiple years to do
really this is gonna be a condensed
timeline but I'll explain exactly how we
got there one of the first things is
data movement but how do we actually get
data from our on-prem to the GCP cloud
and the first thing of course is before
we even get going with lots of projects
is just a basic Internet
right so we have basic proxies and
internet and that doesn't scale
incredibly well what if you need private
services just like they talked about and
the slides before maybe pm's
interconnects we first started using
VPNs and I'm kind of got a love-hate
really read relationship with VPNs some
people like them
I hate VPNs and I'll explain that for a
few reasons
I mean VPNs suck let's face it but if
that's all you can do that's all you can
do right we actually do static routes
there was no cloud router at this point
this is around 2015 so we were stuck
with static routes and no redundancy and
it worked it's something terminated on
prem here and then in terminated inside
the cloud you know it basically did what
it needed to do but we needed something
more robust and we needed to scale high
and so the problems would be p.m. that
was just simple talk about MTU how many
of you ever ever dealt with frame size
issues and MTU problems with VPNs like
everyone's hands gonna Bret MTU is a
terrible thing to deal with in it's not
Google's fault but Google you have to
have fragmentation before encapsulation
and if you've ever dealt with firewalls
and pack and packet captures and why our
captors for why something doesn't work
does your application even support
fragmentation doesn't know what's gonna
be fragmented
I I just need an Advil just talking
about it we dealt with that so long that
we needed to get rid of that speed and
latency is another big thing one of the
big things that I found about speeding
lanes he said if you talk to your
customers sometimes they don't know what
the difference between that is they
might say I need something quick but
it's quick mean I need to load a
terabyte of data in a day or I need a
connection to a database in five
milliseconds sometimes you have to
actually leave that conversation there
to see exactly what they care about
right SLA in the Internet in general
that's the big thing as well you'd come
in one day and your connection across
the Internet's three milliseconds in the
next day it's 45 we've all dealt with
that we actually made a diagram that
makes me show cold potato hot potato
routing to explain to our application
developers and our consumers what it's
like that yes we have internet
connections to the cloud but we don't go
straight there I don't own the
infrastructure in the middle and getting
their heads wrapped around the fact that
yes I may leave here but I don't know
what some tier one provider does with it
after the fact and that's how we explain
that to them so let's see what the VPN
issue first right so what we really
wanted to have a way to have the VPN be
better we couldn't fix the MTU
immediately but we could fix them the
speed of latency problems so this is
where we really started discussing
peering facilities so we actually came
up with if we could get the VPNs closer
to Google we can actually get
performance better so speed latency
reliability SLA so we came up with
peering centers on the east and on the
west coast those are the first good
choices because a lot of the
infrastructure for things that we're
using are there and we have well-defined
lanes use now so instead of using the
Internet we own these private circuits
between some of our daters directly to
these pairing centers so I can tell my
application developers and all my teams
I know what you're going to get from a
late from a latency perspective I know
this it's 15 I know this is 40 and we
don't have to worry about the internet
so what we really did is revisiting the
first slide as we moved the VPN
connections all the way out to the Colo
there in the pairing centers and the VPN
still inside the project so the
Internet's not used right but
reliability and
so I go way up speed is now actually
even better because now we have direct
connections so we're running the VPN
basically on the last mile we're not
running it across the country and hoping
that it gets there we have our own
private circuits that gets us there all
right so the real redundancy actually
still isn't here yet so we actually
started doing multiple VPNs but without
cloud router and static routes and
trying to scale that that's yeah that
didn't work either so we needed to do
something even better than that all
right it actually worked well enough
that we basically started adding more
people liked it so much that we added a
couple more so now we have seven
milliseconds and three we actually have
vendors and application owners that test
this it can get connections straight to
GCP with them 10 milliseconds all right
so once we started doing that thought
well interconnect beta started and if we
could get the interconnect on we can get
rid of the VPNs all right so now we're
gonna fix the VPN issue that's still
problem with the MTU so what happens is
the interconnect beta comes cloud router
comes and we have now an interconnect
plus a direct connect so at each of the
peering facilities we have four
different cables we have two for public
access to Frick interconnect and
depending on what the project needs are
they can do private access or they can
do public access over our own
infrastructure to get the Internet's not
involved and of course with dynamic
routing the redundancy is much more
seamless and it fails were much easier
so with that we basically grew even more
we actually added an another facility
this year and all these sites back each
other out they're talking about
mission-critical reliability you build
this in such a way that when we have
circuit issues and some of these go down
our application owners don't even notice
because if they're multi region and
multi attached to different
interconnects and use pile routers it
automatically fails over all right so
that's we peeled two there now but we're
even adding more and really it's not
just GCP either the journey to actually
getting us connected directly to GCP led
us to other things we're using it for
other providers as well and other
vendors and partners of us and even the
internet itself so just the concept of
getting to GCP led us to this
distributed regionalized network that we
can use and with the combination of
you know new technologies like st-1 and
things like that we can have our remote
sites our stores our distribution
centers we could have them all come to
the closest peering facility and use
cloud services or use the internet and
things that that that they might need
they don't need to come back to the main
offices they don't need to go directly
to the area and we can control that all
in a centralized regionalized man and so
with that being said what we're doing
next is we're investigating what we
exeed they talked about in the last few
slides it is private services via these
channels meaning using our private space
to contact a query and things like that
we're really interested in shared VPC
and we're gonna continue deploying more
pairing centers and keep using the multi
region model and cloud routers and
interconnects and we'll probably even
expand to more caring centers in Canada
and Mexico this year
this models proved extremely well our
customers liked it and we will continue
to do that with that being said as my
talk
[Music]